some republicans are shunning the
partisan press after years of abuse but
now the liberal media is begging them to
come talk florida governor ron desantis
is calling out the view after the
liberal ladies asked him to come on the
show desantis's team responding to the
request with a list of direct personal
attacks from the woke host here are some
examples
you're just short of calling him a
negligent homicidal sociopath because
that's what he is he's risking the lives
of children children's parents their
their grandparents anyone they may come
in contact with so that he could appeal
to his white supremacist base deficit
i think he's a fascist and a bigot it's
anti-black it's anti-gay it's anti-lgbtq
plus it's anti-american and it started
with crt if you start coming after black
people what comes next right
of course the lgbtq house community and
then women and then other marginalized
groups
other republicans are ditching the
mainstream media ahead of the midterms
as well and of course outlets like
politico are mocking them as patty and
claiming that they're making a big
mistake desantis says niet to the view
greg you know um
this is a point that we make a lot uh
demonization eliminates dialogue if
you're gonna say somebody is evil then
that means you can never talk to them
and you just compare what you just saw
there to what we did in the a block we
had none of us
agree with aoc
but we actually were talking seriously
about her we don't believe
it's an important distinction
the right believes
the left is wrong but the left believes
the right is evil and this is an old
krauthammer line and i think this is
always a problem and then they go like
why would you come on the show
because you actually say i'm worse than
hitler also they also they're miserable
you want to go like if you go coming and
you go do fox you have a good time the
people are nice people are fun when
harold and or jessica gets destroyed by
me on the show we still have so much fun
in the break and it and you have to turn
to
fun at dinner we get a little loaded you
never know what happens after that but
then you go let's say you're at the
airport you're forced to watch msnbc or
cnn it's like you wonder who died and
it's their ratings so i think the
problem with legacy media is that
they're still in their shell and when
someone outside their shell joins them
they're it creates meltdowns and it's
very personal it's very personal to them
on the view when they when they run into
something but here it's never unpleasant
because we don't take it personally
that's the difference between
republicans and and hard left people
jessica has let me play with and hold
her child yeah and she's like
no you would never
jesse i haven't even met the kid yet
want to babysit tonight
desantis is smart and the reason why
he's been so successful at promoting his
policies is because he doesn't take the
bait on offers like this so the view is
not interested in having a real serious
conversation about what he's been doing
in florida they probably know he may be
a 2024 presidential candidate that's
probably why they're trying to get him
on early
but if they really believe the things
that they said about him you know he's a
homicidal sociopath a fascist and a
bigot why would you then give him a
platform to continue saying those things
desantis and his team know that they're
trying to use him for gain and they're
not playing this game anymore
republicans across the board aren't
playing the game anymore they're
understanding that you know 96 of the
press
identifies as leftist or liberal and
that it's time to you know make them
give them a fair shot and if that means
ignoring these media outlets that they
don't they don't need to get their
message out um then they can go around
that it's a shame for the people
watching but all they're asking for is a
little bit of fairness and maybe
eventually down the road it's not to be
forever doesn't have to reject the
invitations forever but maybe just a
little reminder about how to have a
decent civil conversation about serious
issues based on the facts which the view
tends to not be interested in pursuing
it if say jesse
desantis went on the view he's also
subjecting his supporters to
the shrill the shrilacious torture
that you have to listen to the oral
torture the woman on the view
so if he did do the view
it would be hard for him to get a word
in because you'd have these women just
yelling and screaming at him the whole
time and
i don't know what the upside would be
for him
right now the mainstream media needs
republicans on the shows because their
shows are boring and no one's watching
the show so all of a sudden you need us
to come on your shows to make your shows
interesting so you guys could get a good
rating sorry uh you called me a murderer
during covet you called me a traitor
during the russia hoax and seven days of
the week you call me racist
and you're working with political
prosecutors to put me in prison
would any of us do well in prison no
have you seen these republican senators
these politicians they wouldn't last a
single day
absolutely not they are working in
tandem with the democratic party so i'm
not going to be your tackling dummy for
a rating
and
they're not doing political journalism
digging if we had a source that
presented
a great scoop that might bring down a
democrat and might affect a political
campaign and you hand it to him
tied it up in a nice bow networks
wouldn't even look at it they would
suppress that story so they're not
actually doing journalism they're doing
partisan propaganda fox now is such a
huge platform and if you add the
internet and the podcast and the radio
to it
you don't need to do these other
networks you don't need to answer
anything
from these guys because you know what
the agenda is you get a much bigger
audience
with the way things are here carol i
differ i think it's taking notes look
out i don't know i take a lot of notes i
think it's short-sighted and
little-minded of politicians to not want
to go and stand in the proverbial
political kitchen and take any heat
if the things that they've said about
him which they've been egregious things
just the clip the montage eclipse we
show demonstrates that i know if someone
called me a fascist and a racist and an
anti-semite i'd want to go on that show
and say i'm not i'd want to go on that
show and have those questions ask me i
don't want the line out there on
television i'm not a racist well i just
gave it to him
but but you know what i mean i
understand but it's being said but i
don't think that's all they would be
asking but whatever they'd ask i would
just say i think this is a pathetic
example of what politics has become
here's what i'm trying to do the country
wants leaders who unite they want
leaders who can listen to each side and
express themselves and if the other side
is outrageous in that conversation let
the country be the judge of that so i i
don't know ron desantis i've read about
him i've heard about him he's got an
impressive resume uh but this is this is
a mark against him in my book uh if you
can't take the tough questions from the
view you probably shouldn't be pressing
you've got to have standards and do
classy shows
not the view you can do prime time but
you could do i'm not talking about
problems i mean do you meet the
president let's do sunday morning talk
show yeah
if santa wants to come on we're happy to
have him
do you want his final word no i look
pensive okay no i'm good i'm just
thinking about what i'm going to eat
ribs
i had ribs last night i had brisket
for lunch succulent yeah my my
expressions made you think about what
you were going for
no it's 5 30 this is when i start
thinking my stomach is growling
i can hear it yeah
succulent not the view hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else